you can create your own luck I think you
need to put yourself in position to
receive the luck so I get a lot of
business in my youtube channel as an
example and I've gotten deals with
Microsoft and sage and big companies
through my youtube channel I've gotten
speaking gigs I've gotten the book deal
mostly to my youtube channel is it lucky
that people happen to search something
on YouTube and one of my videos comes up
or it shows up in the side and then they
click on it and they like it and they
contact me sure I mean think about your
experience you found me somehow somebody
told you about it or maybe you're just
doing a google or youtube search and one
of my videos showed up when you watched
it and you like that you subscribe so
there's a bit of luck to it but I give
myself the best chance at it it's
because I'm producing three to four
videos a days because i love the content
that I'm creating this because I'm proud
of what I'm doing it's because I'm
pouring my heart into making stuff that
I want to show my grandkids and
hopefully you guys are enjoying the
finding value in too so is it a little
bit of luck that people find myself sure
but I'm giving myself the best chance
possible and not just chillin back and
blaming the fact that I don't have any
good luck I think people use luck as a
crutch too often I think people blame
bad luck on their circumstances and then
that's a story that they tell themselves
for the rest of their life I'm from a
poor country so you know I have bad luck
and I won't be successful or my parents
you know I don't know the right parents
so that's my bad luck right in go to the
right school and so that's my bad luck
and that's the story that you tell
yourself for the rest of your life and
then you never break free like as long
as you believe that if you believe you
have bad luck then you're never going to
break 3 you're never gonna be able to do
something amazing and too many people
use that as a crutch I instead of going
out and chasing their dreams I look at
where I'm from sure I'm I'm lucky to
live in Canada I'm lucky to go and have
the parents that i did i'm lucky to have
gone to university and I'm lucky to have
the upbringing environment that I've had
but I created a lot of that for myself
and if you know a nuclear bomb dropped
on Toronto please don't do that and I
somehow managed to survive no matter how
you know badly beaten and bruised I was
I would still go and get mine it doesn't
matter who
means the next presidential election of
its Trump or Hillary I'm still going to
go and get mine it doesn't matter if
they raise taxes a hundred percent I'm
still going to go and get mine the
things that you blame stuff on the
outside environment that you call bad
luck I'm still gonna go and get mine and
if you looked at people who had massive
success they don't blame their
circumstances they don't blame you can
look at somebody and say wow that person
had so much bad luck you look at Abe
Lincoln who ran for office like seven
times and failed who's first of his life
died who's three of his four kids died
before they hit adulthood whose second
wife had depression and had to go to a
mental asylum who Abe Lincoln himself
had the pressure like all this bad luck
that happened to him you could easily
believe that and then that's it give up
and no then he decided I'm gonna run for
president and by some accounts the
greatest president of all time or at
least in the top five because all that
bad luck you look at John Paul DeJoria
who was homeless who you know his
parents gave up on him who had to go to
shelters who joined the gang who did
drugs who had crappy jobs and now he's a
billionaire you look at Oprah who was
made fun of a kid who was so poor that
she wore potato sacks as a dress to
school can't imagine wearing potato tag
potato sacks has addressed to go to
school how much had been made fun of by
the other kids got molested and abused
by her family and their friends had you
know ran away from home had a teenage
pregnancy that didn't work out like all
of this bad luck that happens to these
people and yet they still turn it around
because that's not their story they
refuse to believe that they're just
unlucky and I'm not going to do anything
about it so what if you come for a poor
country so what if you feel like your
disadvantage like you're gonna get beat
down so many times as an entrepreneur
you're gonna get punch to the stomach
hard and then as you're like wobbling
around and trying to kick off that first
punch boom you get hit with an uppercut
and you're down on the mat like that's
entrepreneurship that's life for a lot
of times and so what do you do you just
stay down on the mat you get up you have
to get up if you have the big dream that
you want to chase you want to go out
there you have to get up and stop
blaming bad luck you look at people
who've made it you've had success most
of the time it's they started as nothing
there were self-made and if
look at businesses where the founder
spent decades building something poor
anything they had into it started from
nothing and built this amazing
enterprise and then they hand it off to
their kids what happens most of the time
the kids run it into the ground the kids
who had all the luck in the world had
parents who cared about them grew up in
a business environment had mentors the
learn from had all the luck on their
side and they run the business into the
ground that happens so often so it's not
about bad luck and if you believe that
you just have bad luck and blame it on
that all the time you're never going to
go and reach your goals your minds it
should be no matter what happens in my
external environment I am going to go
get mine that's my thing